i have a good fellas movie poster in the
green room
that i got at an auction a charity
auction at a golf tournament
literally 20 years ago and uh he signed
that along with scorsese
and pesci and de niro and he came out
and said that his
signature was fake fugazi oh my god
and now he's back here on the show the
man who played henry hill and by the way
shoeless joe jackson one of the greatest
sports movies of all time field of
dreams the emmy award-winning actor who
is in the new
soderberg movie which always has me at
hello then you see the cast that's
surrounding
this man don cheadle benicio del toro
jon hamm kieran culkin brendan fraser
bill duke and ray liotta who's back here
on the rich eisen show how are you sir
how you been good at you did you put the
poster back
up i put the poster back up uh it's got
your new signature on it with the old
one crossed out that you
uh just like you know with your initials
on it it's up on the wall damn straight
it is oh yeah
oh yeah including the the where where
you bashed it with a hammer to try and
open it up back in the day
uh we put the glass back up ray you are
immoral
immortalized here in this studio no
doubt all right good
good it'll be worth more money now i
love it
how have you how's everything how you
been life's good for you ray
good yeah can't complain i mean after
the past year that we had
right there was a lot of rest and
relaxation whether you wanted it or not
but
now things are picking up and working
away this movie no sudden booze
did you guys work we're yeah we've been
on the air uh pretty much
um you know last year uh during the
pandemic didn't talk much sports
obviously but now
you know knocking on wood we're we're
back in the mix uh
we're everything's awesome and then i
mean this new movie that you are in
that's gonna be hitting
uh exclusively premiering hbo max on
july 1st
soderbergh this is this the first
soderberg movie you've you've been in
ray were you yeah yeah that was the main
reason why i wanted to do it too to work
with him he's one of the few directors
of that
cover different genres right and
he's just he just knows his stuff and
knows what he wants so it was great
working with him
okay any is there any any um
uh connective tissue similarities
between him and scorsese that you can
throw out
from your experiences right well
i think they when what they read the
script and they know
what it is that that they want i don't
they don't
write shot lists per se but in their
head they know i'm sure
it feels like they're the movie is
edited
uh in their head as we go along so what
we
film it might not feel complete but he
knows he just wants to use a certain
part of it
and uh in that way and then
marty too he does the different genres
uh
but they're just they they they have a
vision and they're very they're involved
in every second of
of what's on screen and uh what
direction does he give you ray i mean
what
what uh how does he you know communicate
with you and
and work on a character like that for a
movie like this one
said in 1950s detroit not
not much he's he's quiet
about it i think he takes his time
casting he he casts
people that he feels that are right for
the roles uh this isn't exactly new
territory for me in terms of what i'm
playing
so he just kind of you know he
he works behind the camera he he's the
camera operator
so he sees things in a very unique way
but but
uh he doesn't say what marty was the
same way
that they're not sitting there giving
you all kinds of direction as opposed to
just letting you go and
and seeing what you bring to it ray
leota here on the rich eyes and show a
few minutes with the
uh the emmy award-winning actor no
sudden move premiering exclusively on
hbo max on july first
uh directed by steven soderbergh uh in
the
segment we just showed of your last
appearance six years ago you said you've
only seen goodfellas twice
is that still that number six years
later you've still only seen it twice
i've never seen field of dreams either
come on now whoa all right now
now right you know if we weren't you
know uh
somebody who know each other uh for for
this amount of time
those are fighting words to a man like
me i'm not gonna lie to you those are
fighting words they're what
those are fighting words to a man like
me those are fighting words
what do you mean you've never seen fight
i've only been in one fight my whole
life
what which what fight is that right it's
like
in seventh grade that was it
that's it okay it's true all right so uh
really all right um instead of asking
you why have you only seen it once but
how did you come about uh field of
dreams how are you offered the role did
you know at the time that this was going
to be
an iconic sports film ray walk me
through that if you don't mind
well you don't know at all i remember i
read it and that was only my third movie
and i said this is so
silly this guy he hearing voices
and he's got cornfield and he makes a
baseball field he removes the corn
i just could at that time because i
never wanted to do this stuff so i
wasn't i wasn't like
movie aware and saw lots of movies it
just kind of happened in college because
i didn't want to take math
and so so when i read the script i just
thought it was the silliest silliest
thing
and obviously i was wrong so and then
you're playing shoeless joe jackson
coming out of the corn
um and uh and going through it
it was how much time do you spend in
iowa for that right
uh probably a like month and a half a
month have you ever been back to iowa is
that the only time
i was disappointed because during the
pant during the pandemic
the yankees and somebody else were going
to have a game
in the field of dreams in iowa and that
never happened obviously because of
pandemic but i was going to go to that
and that would have been really cool no
kidding you were supposed to go to you
were supposed to you were supposed to
make an appearance it's something like
that
for for for yeah for years it was a
regular season game
right it wasn't it wasn't like
exhibition it was a huh
yeah no i yeah absolutely so so commence
you've never seen it
would you i mean would you're not even
curious about seeing
field of dreams you're not even curious
because everyone talking about it was
just more
it was more of a personal thing my mom
was sick at the time
we sat down to watch it but she couldn't
really
enjoy herself so we left and i don't
know i just equate it with that i will
someday maybe well i would i'd i'd
watch myself a lot well i'd love to i'd
love to watch it with you ray
i mean you know not to invite myself
over to your house but you know that
would be
amazing that would be something i'll
i'll do something like that
so um all right so this is a fun this
looks like a total blast like a fun
movie that uh you enjoyed doing when you
were on the set
and i you know i can't wait to see it
right i know you're at a junket and you
got lots going on but uh
uh this is this is something i look
forward to seeing and i'd love to have
you back here in studio at something
yeah
thank you i appreciate that you got it
thanks for the call right you be well
okay rich okay man you got it that's ray
liotta everybody at ray liotta
right here on the rich eisen show on
instagram hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that
watch more right here